mayors across the united states are
going absolute ham on bitcoin the mayors
have realized that they get a incredible
benefit from going ahead and becoming
not only sympathetic to bitcoin but
trying to plug their cities into the
decentralized digital network what am i
talking about we have this quote from a
business professor at stanford he said
mayors rationally want to attract
high-income citizens who pay their taxes
and impose few costs on the municipality
crypto geeks fit this bill perfectly hey
joseph maybe you're a geek nah just
kidding but of course that is ultimately
what cities are trying to do is that
they are trying to attract high-income
citizens that are not a big burden on
the municipality and so by being able to
attract bitcoins or crypto enthusiasts
that is a great strategy we have seen
everyone from mayor conger the mayor of
jackson tennessee a place that most
people had never even heard of before go
ahead and say you know what i'm gonna
pledge to give my city employees the
option of converting paychecks into
bitcoin he outlined a plan to install a
digital mining network in a deserted
wing of city hall and he also is trying
to figure out other ways he can generate
new coins for the city we have this
quote where he said bitcoin is a great
financial equalizer it's a hedge against
inflation it can bridge that wealth gap
this is not a guy who's trying to get
rich this is a guy who's trying to help
his citizens from everything he said
publicly we then have eric adams the new
york city mayor the brand new mayor
coming in he said new york city is going
to be the center of the cryptocurrency
industry another fast-growing innovative
industries just wait we're waiting mayor
let's see what happens and then of
course we have francis suarez the mayor
of miami he continues to just go ham on
bitcoin takes a portion of his salary in
bitcoin he is already positioned by the
crypto capital he urged the conference
of mayor members to sign a crypto
compact and he is calling on government
to refrain from overly aggressive
regulation in the crypto market mayor
suarez really working as not only the
chief marketing officer of miami but
working to get things done underneath
the surface trying to make sure that his
citizens have all the tools they need to
be successful
cheering for their success which is what
we need more of he's got this quote
where he said people are losing
purchasing power every single day
they're not earning interest which is
why they're seeking alternative
investments like crypto i agree with him
i think that he's onto something here
and then of course our boy jason stewart
the mayor of cool valley missouri
bitcoin is fundamentally american facts
it is the most american thing facts our
government is built on freedom and
personal liberty facts and rights and
self-sovereignty facts and all the
things that bitcoin really is facts i
think it's a natural marriage that
bitcoin in america will thrive i agree
with you mayor stewart and i appreciate
all the hard work that you've got going
on there in cool valley missouri as well
it doesn't matter what city you're from
you're in new york or miami or you're
literally in jackson or cool valley if
you're a mayor and you plug your city
you plug your citizens into the bitcoin
network you'll be reminded very quickly
bitcoin's good for business bitcoin's
good for politics and bitcoin is the
most american technology that we have
right now john what do you think yeah
bitcoin is good for business i think
mayor suarez suarez laid out the
playbook for mayors across the nation
that if you are receptive to people in
the crypto industry um there are a ton
of crypto enthusiasts who will even move
to your city um just to do that right
miami has a bunch of very attractive
things to it but a bunch of people came
here because of the mayor's policies and
thoughts around bitcoin jason stewart in
cool valleys doing similar things and
other mayors around the the nation are
coming this like consensus of like hey
bitcoin is really good for business and
we want these people to come to our city
build in our city and become a
technology helper a crypto hub for the
united states joe what do you think yeah
i think it's good look the best
politicians what we've seen over time is
they can act uh political in some realms
where they get along with people and
they can they can push things forward
working with both political parties but
ultimately the best ones operate and are
entrepreneurs right they have that
mindset of hey let's let's align
incentives and push these things forward
and make sure that we are treating
people with respect people are doing the
right things people can live prosperous
life they have freedom they have all
these things so we're seeing it all
across the country to your point from
miami and new york to tennessee and
stuff and ultimately what i think we're
going to find is just more people are
going to do this it's becoming a topic
that is all ingrained within culture and
people are demanding this stuff out of
their politicians and they want to know
hey i'm going to move if you're not
doing these things so people are going
to vote with their feet and i think more
politicians are going to see that and
want to want to adapt